nous sommes en avril le 26,2 en 1986 il
y à 27 ans la centrale de tchernobyl
explosé comme un volcan dans
l'atmosphère le réacteur incontrôlée et
mais ces matières qui forment un énorme
nuage de poussière et de gaz qui voyage
autour de la terre
à la manière d'une vigile les
associations anti-nucléaires
saint-quentinoise commémore cette date
anniversaire depuis six ans samedi ils
se sont rejoints à montigny le
bretonneux pour déposer une gerbe face
au site du leader mondial de l'énergie
nucléaire areva nous sommes venus rendre
hommage donc aux victimes de tchernobyl
en 1986 il ya 27 ans c'était le 26 avril
donc rendre hommage aux victimes du
nucléaire rappeler que le nucléaire
n'est pas une fatalité qu'on peut
arrêter en france le nucléaire est
partout dans le monde aussi la fortiori
en france et en plein débat national sur
la transition énergétique il est
important de rappeler qu'il ya des
alternatives au nucléaire
4000 morts selon l'om est ce plus de
deux cent mille victimes pour greenpeace
à tchernobyl pour louanger le risque est
à prendre au sérieux aussi en france en
france pour l'instant dieu merci on n'a
pas eu de catastrophe nucléaire ce genre
mais si on regarde le nombre de
centrales parce que pas par habitant la
france est le pays le plus nucléarisé du
monde douillet donc si on regarde les
probables pied d'accident on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une sorte d'un accident
nucléaire la france compte 58 réacteurs
nucléaires dans 19 centrales et est le
deuxième producteur d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire au monde derrière
les etats unis les gens nous faire
comprendre à coucher
l'industrie nucléaire notre avenir
gravement aubert